i am a u.s citizen i am a u.s assortment
i showed up outside the u.s embassy and
i literally begged them to let me in
it's embarrassing they will not
i tried everything i could
they hang up the phone on me several
times i begged them
i was the tears right afterwards it was
that embarrassing
a us citizen
is not permitted entry
in u.s soil
they caused this big mess and now
they're hiding behind these walls
and they will not even agree to open the
gates for a u.s citizen i call the usnbc
number
they won't pick up i call the second
number online
and i told them i'm a u.s citizen i want
to come in they said what about they say
about my own family
and a few other individuals that i
cannot talk about over the phone but i
would like to come in and discuss this
matter in person the hang of the phone i
called again and again the same thing
good afternoon i need to come into the
u.s embassy
i know and i called twice after that
after i checked the website and they
just keep transferring me
please try to understand me i really
need to come in and speak to an american
[Music]
good afternoon sir i just spoke to
someone and they asked me to schedule an
appointment the only two appointments
you have
good afternoon i need to come into the
u.s embassy
and see an american representative of
the embassy i am an american citizen
i am a us citizen this is my seventh
year
first of all we can't transfer
right now are you at the u.s embassy
will you ask me for english
he transferred me
i couldn't believe it i wasn't shocked i
said i am a us citizen i am a staff
sergeant in the u.s army i want to come
in
are you going to permit me entry or no
they hung up the phone on me again i
gave up i gave up they kept hanging up
no matter what i say they kept hanging
out i left the area i got back in the
car
when i was far away from that area i
started i started tearing up i couldn't
believe it it felt like
somebody was stabbing me in my back but
i wanted to go to the u.s embassy like i
said first to get my old family out get
some sort of assurances from them get
information apply for humanitarian
parolees
ask them for assistance with the
pakistani foreign ministries at the
border right now there are u.s green
card holders there's an american citizen
that i've seen
there are
afghans who have sivs
that are stuck isis k is all over this
place
and
there are
rumors that al-qaeda is
is
back in afghanistan and then the taliban
are ramping up their uh
counter-offensive against isis k so they
have set up checkpoints and they're
first killing everyone searching
everyone so these afghan allies that we
have us citizens green card holders
they have to get past all these
checkpoints and then
not only hide from the taliban but also
isis k and then al-qaeda i mean isis is
targeting directly u.s citizens green
card holders anyone with an afghan
passport wanting to get out they're in
search of these guys and then the
pakistanis are asking for noc's
non-objection certificates even though
this family has actual uh pakistani
visas issued by pakistani foreign
ministry but these guys won't let them
in
you can bribe your way in at this point
and it changes from 300 to 700
per person
you have to have a visa you pay the
bribe and they will let you in however
they will not
stamp your passport with an entry step
and so there were groups at the border
that made it they paid their bribe
and they they crossed the border they
entered pakistan
50 kilometers later pakistani police
stops them
brings them back to the border but this
time now they hand them over back to the
taliban and they were running away from
the taliban to begin with they're just
stuck there they can't even return to
kabul now because of all these taliban
checkpoints that are recent because of
isis so these guys came to the border
hoping to get out
but now they're stuck there they're all
begging
they're all begging the u.s embassy to
step in that u.s embassy is here
for this purpose
they're supposed to serve u.s citizens
abroad
[Music]
there's a big chunk of that embassy
assigned just for citizen services but
they're refusing entry from u.s citizens
however when you when you uh go online
and and you see media of course state
department claims uh how they're
they're bragging about how they're
helping afghan allies well you're not
you're lying you're not even permitting
entry to us citizens we completed one of
the biggest airlifts in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than 5
500 americans out
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
this is what i can do i can come on fox
news and plead for help
i've done everything else in my power
i've come here myself
i'm in dire needle of help if there's
anyone out there that can help me help
my family help all these other
individuals us citizens us green corner
holders our afghan allies please please
help us
we're in dire need of help